good morning everyone okay y'all good
morning millennial um hey how are you
doing I'm okay I feel like I'm hungover
all the time and I don't want to
complain about it but like I really
don't feel good I don't feel like we've
been doing a lot of shows hungover
though I feel like we've been doing
shows like tired not well yeah I went to
Taylor Swift the night before yeah went
to a long dinner but not like true
hangover no and because of my shows
being take that girl job job because of
my shows being on the weekends like I
really haven't drank and it's like in a
month except for on your birthday two
weeks ago that was awesome you're
hungover I forgot about an Atlantic City
oh yeah yeah two weeks two weeks two
weeks anyways we are at a long time uh a
week and a half for us a week and a half
and sure no the last time I had a drink
was Saturday the 14th ok in Atlantic
City
and today's only it's the 25th to 28th
11 days a week and a half
14th to the 25th Saturday to Wednesday
we can have Wow feels like a lot longer
anyways do you miss this feeling no like
not at all my back hurts and I've known
my second Pedialyte and like it's just
not helping I have like the throbbing
pain in my forehead
Oh your first Pedialyte really didn't
help I drank some last night too like
that's a waste precious and it was my
red one which is the better flavor it's
such a waste to drink Pedialyte the may
before like you think you're being
proactive but it's just a waste of the
good no I didn't take Advil before bed
which was my magic drink water try and
get as hydrated as possible and then
you'll suffer the consequences the next
day but they're inevitable and you're
wasting precious cargo if you're doing
pretty elated well it was like I went to
this birthday party where I thought I
wasn't gonna know anyone and I'd
literally end up knowing like knowing
knowing knowing knowing everyone there
so like I was just like it was perfect
recipe for a good time and I had a great
time I have no regrets like this sucks
but I had a great time yeah the only
regret is that it's only Wednesday this
week is just slowly carrying on and it's
a torturous week you guys but you know
what you know what I'm Taylor Swift she
killed us on Sunday but also the past
two weeks of the toast have been
unbelievable record breaking cream you
Larry
like never been better in all of our
years of doing this so what we're
basically trying to say is we might be
taking tomorrow off no it's just like
you know you got to take the highs and
the lows and today is very much a low
yeah I'm very feeling very low and and
even more low is like Mark Zuckerberg
can't get his like [ __ ] [ __ ] together
and Facebook live is down so we're only
on YouTube today so if you're hearing
this you already are on YouTube so I
don't know what the point of making the
announcement was but like tell your
friends if someone's like where's the
stream there's someone in like the
Facebook oops take this show today yeah
like let's give them an extra 30 seconds
because everyone is like late and slow
all the time go tell your friends to
come to YouTube how do you see how many
people are watching very slow show how
do you see how many people I never want
Joe to you don't don't see you don't
tell you not right here YouTube who's
the CEO of Google someone who's like not
as thirsty as Mark Zuckerberg cuz his
name like seeds out of the good for him
but he invented Google like a team of
people I think that's just like who
invented water do you know what I mean
it's like nobody invented it no but it's
like who invented the internet okay yeah
so someone invented Google he's just
like doesn't really like to be in the
public eye I guess but Rebecca works at
Google so whenever like the CEO comes to
speak show he's Instagram stories it's
so I I think I could pick him up line up
like we know Jeff Bezos because Jeff
Bezos is a thirst monster general and
you know what if I invented a piece of
the Internet I would be so thirsty like
it would know no bounds totally so I
understand oh people can see there's
1158 people watching hey [ __ ] oh that's
great hey okay you know what
we've been giving you hour-long shows
plus guest or no guests for the past few
weeks and today we're gonna slow things
down
so without further ado they're going to
do please burp the other way sorry that
was like that was a catastrophic birth I
don't mind a burp but just if you could
turn your head I'm sorry I forgive you
without further ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and they are all
celeb filled because the celebs did not
stop making news yes like I'm done being
smart can we go back to normal life
please um only
when there's something to talk about I
still will not talk about the fact that
Pete Davidson commented on ariana
grande's photo this that and the other
that instrument' comments are no longer
accepted as news stories right so I
still will be going to CNN money to hear
what Ilana is up to you when there is a
dry spell but today it has rained and
when it rains it pours when it rains it
pours Oh when it rains it pours nice
okay first story is really sad it's my
brain moaning man she woke up fat mad
bitching and moaning about Sam I'm gonna
see something controversial I think I
don't know I think Lou Combs is hot we
already said that in this activity like
like he has big dick energy oh my god
totally he's the definition of big dick
energy when we saw him that stagecoach
what was it see anyhow I was like Sam
daddy yes he was walking on the stage
with his Red Solo Cup like big dicks
which mean his legs that's why he was so
slow and he just did not give a [ __ ] and
he's standing there cup in hand I think
he had a dip in his mouth yeah just
harmonizing it's like hitting the notes
he doesn't rehearse see they just throw
him on stage in there like do your thing
Luke oh yeah it's really a sight to see
and have you seen his girlfriend she's
like so hot and she's a toaster yeah oh
my god she is so like they're just goals
and I look forward to one day triple
dating with them by the way as you know
the boys would get along with him oh my
god Zack in him no I really think I
found my way like into the elite of
country music and it's through the
spouses
it is because now I have Luke Holmes's
wife girlfriend
I have Brian Kelly not TP G's wife Brian
Kelly a by the way so when you're gone
for a week I started booking something
else I saw Jackie's where you going by
the way I'm going like on a boat of the
coast of Europe on a boat we head you're
gonna die I'm aware I watched below-deck
last night oh my god I've caught up on
on Team USA I need to talk about below
decks I know you think it's a great
specialist and I had to Marga it's truly
the ready show no the great show is this
show we of course sorry we're sorry and
it's also like this story about a man
who loses
morning show and has to rebuild and
toxify the river anyways stop reading
the comments how can you see that in my
glass I'm gonna have to confiscate your
phone okay sorry sorry class is in
session but I'm sorry miss I'll show you
particular okay watch below check med
which I hadn't watched since last season
when I really liked Malia and you said
that she was a [ __ ] starter i but i
haven't seen on the episode so I was
like maybe I missed the part where she
sucks yeah but I know that I didn't I
watch ice tonight's episode Hannah is
the worst so I didn't watch it but it's
she captain's head he gets really mad at
her really mad at her but she's pulling
the [ __ ] that she always pulled it's
like she thinks she's too good to be
working on a boat so then don't work on
a boat like no their girls are working
so hard she gets sick with an anxiety
attack so she has to take the day off
and some squeegee girl who does the both
sides
oh yeah has bronchitis oh my god I know
exactly who you're talking about but I
don't know her name cuz she's like so
irrelevant she's so irrelevant she's the
token squeegee girl who does right
there's always one girl on the on deck
who works with the men and she's like I
grew up with a lot of brothers like I
love to be in the water she was like
knew this was the weirdest and she said
she has bronchitis so she can't sweet
she and she's actually sick no she's
actually sick and they actually put her
in I think a guest cabin because she
looks about nice yes she needed to be
alone and she said something so weird
she's like I grew up horseback riding
everyday so it's so hard for me to just
not squeegee like no I know what you
meant like I always worked so like me
being away she was being a horseback
rider like that it's just like the most
elite hot total possibly has you go back
to Hannah give me a brief synopsis
is having anxiety and I guess like it's
really bad and it's causing her to throw
up she can't keep her food down so she's
just on her top bunk all day like making
her anxiety worse in her claustrophobic
cabin I don't understand and like those
cabins laying around in her song but
like the camera like the permanent
camera is right there like up her vagina
it's she knew she knew it's just so
strange and she's dating like the
younger guy who's really cute so anyways
there are two people down the guy who
doesn't like onions is back harboring
the boat and they need to obviously make
amends and I saw the old onion episode
okay so he brings these hats hashtag no
onions which is hilarious cut up and the
chef Adam yeah are all chefs named Adam
no just this one oh my god that's what
Carole's boyfriend should do next is be
a chef on below deck totally that's like
a generosity like a team player no but
it would be perfect yeah anyways so he's
trying to make amends onion man and
everybody's working ot for Kenny and his
crew except for there are two people
down and things have never run smoother
she captain sandy said it was the
quickest beach picnic that they ever set
up like everything's going so well the
two girls who like Joe are whoa wow it's
like JWoww spelled out Wow the two girls
legs Wow are just the only two stews
yep and they're working side by side
harmoniously no drama whatsoever
the brunette girl who's like really has
her should it's just like taking charge
and she still with you ow
and also do you know that she like Annie
met her because he she was working on a
few boats that he chartered so I guess
he put her on the show because she's
gonna hurt she was on watch what happens
live one time and I happened to catch it
by the way um it's Andy on the Britney
stage one of our stories yes um
so everything's going so well because
hannah is not there then she finally
gets better she's like you know what I
have to either leave the boat or I have
to just put on a brave face from her
from her illness which it's like it's
hard to glean what how real her anxiety
because you know we can't see you can't
hear the cost right but she is throwing
up a lot and like she clearly said this
is something that she struggles with but
I just don't think that being a chief
stew is something as someone with
anxiety should have where they literally
can't move or leave you're trapped so I
don't know I just don't think it's a
great job Jois totally anyway she comes
back and she's trying to like just work
through it and literally all she does is
gossip
and then she's trying to like hang out
with the with the patron she did him on
a boat thing and she's like in their
photos like trying to flirt with the guy
in front of his wife and she hooked up
with a guy last les summer I know Jason
yeah he was all yeah totally and be like
so inappropriate and having Sandy had it
up to her ears I'm like you know what I
completely agree with habitat II and I
hope no Captain Tenny is the most
rational boss
she really at first he's gonna so
Solomon well we came from captain Lee
who was like ruthless you [ __ ] up once
he gets you a ticket like so ticket home
like he was so ruthless and then captain
said II in her first season was a little
soft but I feel like she's a really good
captain she's a really good captain
Hanna he's a horrible cheats you they
should know Hannah takes advantage of
her position it literally feels like
camp when like the Greek leaders would
like sit and like not do anything in eat
snacks all day and like the counselors
who get paid literally no money like are
out in the fields and I feel like what
happens is they do the show they achieve
a level of Fame they're being flown in
for watching happens I'd they're saying
at the Gansevoort they become the people
that they're serving and now she's like
why the [ __ ] am i cleaning up after
these breaks I'm going on the boat with
them we're gonna take shots of tequila
yep because she like doesn't think that
she should be serving them anymore but
then like then you're missing the point
of the show right that's a good point so
in Italy I'm the reason sorry you're
going to gear up we took quite a I'm
going to hear it I'm out here it's for
four days I think or five days I it's a
it's a Monday to Friday in August so I
feel like I'm always gone so you get
co-host but like now you're never gone
and now you are so I get cause so I've
already booked two days to tell us
record I just feel like we need two days
to catch up and like everyone lobster
one day with the points guy and I need
two more I'm just so excited like to
have a cup host it's exciting it is but
then you all their breakfast like no one
can do this shot no it's and by the way
you realize that it's hard and like one
like someone I forget who was who has
sat down and like gotten nervous and
like well he knows about it's a tiny
little web show right I mean then that
gets not know right people that we've
had can do the job but it's hard to find
fili first also no one lives in New York
and I really want to guide all someone
who is like aware loving yeah and that
people know and that like is a host and
that knows what's going on in the world
yeah it's no it's not an easy job no
it's not an easy job so it's interesting
to try and find the co-hosts and jury's
still out on if we're doing a show
Friday the way this week is going like
it's just not looking I'm gonna be a
Phoenix sweating my absolute dick off
and I don't know if the show sold out I
think it might be but had to grow up
with no job I'm not considering we keep
saying like we were gonna do summer
fridays we've actually never worked
harder in the summer so I don't feel bad
taking up Friday off no me neither and
we did we should say we're gonna do
summer fridays and we never got back
when we had the backing of a media
company no we said it here to me yeah
and then we never did so this might be
our first summer Friday you guys also
all the people shouting bar stool people
just for the record every time I ask
them ever since you know our big scandal
they said no so like oh really yeah they
can grab sin grab a spoon I never asked
anyone but I know I won't I feel like we
were talking about something and we got
derailed we were talking about before
the co-hosts that we're gonna co-host
thing I was asked to jump into the Fast
Five I was singing Luke combs yeah Brian
Kelly right that's how they did it we
finally okay yeah so I was saying that
our way into their country musically
like backstage at CMAs is gonna be
through the wives so Brian Kelly who's
one of the members of our Georgia line
his uh wife yeah she is now in my DMS I
have mrs. Luke combs I've Lorna Lena
like we're slowly we're slowly getting
we're psyllium pervading real in real a
virus Kelsey we're totally apart we need
to get like to like Brad Paisley Carly
Paris Carly pars she feather her [ __ ] is
good so good I feel like I slept on it
for a while but like had the wine is so
good she and everywhere Dan yes I know
every little thing is amazing I remember
every little thing
okay we need to give us the past five
stories because a lot has gone down
specifically Demi Lovato overdosed
yesterday oh my god I was when you
posted it on our Instagram I didn't even
see it
I was so shook because like I feel like
when you're open about your sobriety
like you're so much more vulnerable and
like open to criticism and I'm like I
just like I don't know I I was just like
so shocked by it it's so it's so
shocking there have been a lot of
contradicting reports sort of but right
now she is stable after being
hospitalized following an apparent
overdose so at first TMZ reported that
it was a Herren overdose and they used
narcan and she's stabilized by the way
narcan is the craziest thing what is it
it's literally like a heroin reversal
and if they find you in time they take
an EpiPen they like inject you with it
you literally come back to life Wow I've
learned about it in shameless because
one of the guys is a EMT and he doesn't
ever have enough of it and like
literally every every like service
person like has to carry it that's so
crazy it's the craziest drug still
literally magic while TMZ reported that
the overdose was heroin related a source
close to Lovato claims to people that it
is not oh um Lovato has battled
addiction mental illness and disordered
eating for years in 2010 she entered
treatment where she was treated for
bipolar disorder believe me a self harm
an addiction she relapsed after she left
the treatment center then entered a
sober living facility a year later you
know she was living in a sober living
facility while she was a judge on X
Factor yeah she was looking a half way
not not a halfway house what's it called
like um before you go home after rehab
it's like an in-between yeah and she was
literally going home to this like bunk
bed while she was making 25 million
dollars on X Factor that's so crazy I
know I I so one we heard that she
overdosed on heroin then I read
something I think it might have been in
the toast that she overdosed on
oxycottons but then would that require
narcan to revive you I'm not a hundred
person I'm not a hundred percent sure so
it's unclear what happened all we know
is that we're thinking of her we're and
the whole world is really praying for
her and like it's just so sad because I
feel like because she's been so reading
the comments all the time she want to
know why I'm sorry I'm not because
YouTube comments disappear and I want to
see what people are saying what are
people saying you need to check up this
squeezie girl on squeegee girl on
Instagram she had a glow up since the
show her name is Jamie she was beautiful
even with
- people just think Stassi would be the
best which she really would if she was
in New York I would I would pay her a
thousand dollars from the company no not
my personnel sorry I just want to say um
Oh someone heard that it was opioids
okay that demi overdosed on relapsed is
very common while becoming sober and
because you haven't had any drugs in a
long time a little amount of drugs can
affect you way more than it normally
would
yeah narcan can work on open any opioid
narcan works on oxy - okay so it could
have been it could have been a lot of
different things it's just really sad
and I mean she's just so open about it
that I feel like we're all on this
journey with her you know as your host
like if she would it's all this time
she'd the she never put out that song
sober where she told us that she wasn't
sober anymore lling she was pretending
to like still be sober and then this
happened I think it would it would be
even more shocking but like when you
watch her documentary and like she talks
about how every single day she has to
like keep herself busy who not think
about like drugs or food or all these
other things that she battles your
addiction with like it's that's so
tiring I know that's why she's like a
literary work out I do martial arts for
six hours a day like so when I heard
this the the news I was obviously really
sad about it but like what made me even
more sad is like the level of
celebrities that just like tweeted about
it and like just were like wishing her
well it really made me realize how like
she really is like a good person and
like she doesn't really have beef with
anyone like we heard that she'd like a
falling out with Nick Jonas but like not
like stupid beats like him tweeted about
her like literally everyone I feel like
except she does have beef with Selena
but like I understand anything she has
beef with ki5 town she was through
Selena like her and Sano just can't be
friends anymore for obvious reasons like
if she's living like this sober life and
Selena like it's just not I totally
understand but like it was just really
impressive like how many people were
just like sending her positive thoughts
and then I'm just thinking like she
really is like a well not now obviously
but she's like a good role model like
for kids and like she still is a good
role model because like she's at least
honest about all of this like some
people just over those people in
Hollywood do drugs are addicted to drugs
and then step out on the red carpet and
pretend to be like a teen idol and right
she is just real with people and like it
I think she helps a lot of people feel
like they can relate to her or like talk
about their addiction oh yeah no I like
really like I have so much respect for
her and her docume
was amazing I just was she's saying it a
little bit more um and when you know
when she said that thing like I'll ever
have to wake up every day and just try
not to think about all the things I'm
addicted to it was just like so shook
were they like after six years of being
sober like that's tiring yeah so it's
like it's really sad and like I just
couldn't believe how many celebrities
every single person on my timeline yeah
okay that kid well they're different
because Demi has always come to bat for
Kim I totally agree her bigger I'll
stick together I love their relationship
me too actually
except I did meet a blind ooh it was
really sad actually what it was like
when something about like body
positivity and Demi said something about
Kim like being like a curvy girl like
really like it was an empowering thing
and I don't know where I read this but
it was I can oh basically being like
don't call me Todd do you know any mean
yeah I guess I like it so it's Kim curvy
I don't know because she's really skinny
and she's like a fake fat ass so like no
but like she has occurred right but
Kirby means more like a figure no now it
means fulfill a curvy means you're not
this writer this I don't know if I hit
her Kim curving but Kim is the
definition of she is curvy but now just
curvy has a gentle meeting okay I knew
their term so Demi still in the hospital
Sammy's in the house we haven't heard
from her no but her people say that
she's stable and she's with her family
um teams you reported that she owed heed
after partying all night long I feel
like there's two different stories
coming out like TMZ kind of has like the
real story cuz they like work with the
police and like they have a mole in the
hospital disguised as a nurse right but
then you know Demi's people kind of just
like want to keep it low-key
low-key and and she's always been super
honest with her friends but like it's
literally the day of everyone needs to
relax
everyone needs to relax and I don't
expect to have answers and I look
forward to her recovery and hearing from
her soon but like when a picture of her
living in a club but like in the middle
the night with Chi not with cheese he'd
like right after gez like jay-z just not
give me good vibes
I think definitely is like not a good
you know influence on a sober person to
get there now and he said they were
together inside oh but they didn't leave
together that picture was was false so
like I feel like we knew something bad
was coming I just it was gonna be this
yeah and I think even she knew it when
she sang that song and then put it out
right
you know when you think that when
someone are out that it's like it's
behind them do you know anything they
got to put a song out in the middle of a
bender yeah no but she did because
that's how real she is with her fans and
he's so real it's it's commendable and I
just hope she gets the help that she
meet you I really feel for her like I
just like I can't get over how many
people were just like like no one in
Hollywood cares about each other but
like everyone cares about Demi Lovato
and I feel like everyone really like
empathizes for people with addiction
yeah especially people who are honest
about it right that's the whole thing
it's like honestly her like she would be
a great friend for Selena right but
Selena doesn't want help no and Demi is
not in a place where she can take on
someone else's burden and the first step
is acceptance and she can't do that
but someone put something in the dosers
group of her i'm fabletics ads are like
still running on instagram stories it
like says that it's like a play it's
like her Instagram story but it's like
promote it it's like come on guys really
yeah that's not so bad
I know it's just whatever worst case
it's just it's like that's just the
world that we live in do you know any me
yeah how like things go on do you know
what I mean it's so weird but sometimes
it's like no grossly inappropriate this
isn't no and by the way it wasn't on
purpose I'm sure it's like a promotion
that they have running for months and
then things like stop it yeah but also
it's not like she's promoting like
healthy living right right Oh true
you know talk of a friend right okay
next story is exciting
Carly Klaus is engaged to Joshua Kushner
quote their hearts are full her their
ring is huge
supermodel Karlie Kloss and her
boyfriend Joshua Kushner are engaged
after 6 years of dating a source close
to the couple confirmed their engagement
to people saying quote he proposed a few
weeks ago during a romantic weekend
together in upstate New York cute the
source adds they're both overjoyed and
happily celebrating their hearts are
full and they're excited to build their
future together wait if you propose a
few weeks ago then like why is she
acting like it just happened now saying
like I'm getting all these messages like
your close friends and family must have
already known oh yeah that's where
church are true cloths confirm the news
on Instagram posting a sunset selfie of
her new fiance quote I love you more
than I have words to express she wrote
Josh you're my best friend my soul mate
I can't wait for forever together yes a
million times over so there's two levels
to this story yes one is the beard of it
all that the blinds say that both of
them are gay and they're both just like
you know
they're perfect together because they
get to like it makes sense Karlie Kloss
is a supermodel Jared crusher comes like
a no not Jared josh Josh Kushner comes
from like a very wealthy like socialite
family like it makes sense that they
would be dating but the fact that
they're both gay it's like it's the
perfect cover up like frill the second
level is just like the connection the
president right so like this is all I
can think about you know that I've Anka
commented on her picture saying like so
happy sister exhalation no it's so weird
like do you think Taylor Swift and
Donald Trump are gonna be the same room
I don't think Donald's is gonna go for
the wedding he's not gonna go uh I don't
know like there was a girl that I knew I
forget how but like her the guy that she
married was like distantly related to
Ivanka and he found his family no no I
don't know Ivanka was supposed to be at
the wedding but she didn't go cuz she
did want to like take attention away
from the bride and it was like a whole
thing so I feel like like I don't know I
feel like they wouldn't go no here's
here's a person and then I read is a
most disgusting tweet that I have to
share a week obviously written by some
[ __ ] who works at the Daily Beast okay
here's the comparison it's like I'm
engaged and me inviting Trump to the me
inviting Ben's parents to so it is is
like them invite us home
so it's like pretty close yeah look
obviously but obviously many parents are
knighted wait that's so close no no it's
so we obviously it's less likely that
Taylor Swift is America's they're not
friends right now oh right no but just
like the caliber of people that Carly's
friends with like just being in the same
room as saddled Trump it's like not a
good association like they're gonna kill
each other there's gonna be murders wait
I have to read you this sweet like I've
been following like all these tales for
fan accounts and I follow this girl
who's just like so she's definitely like
an older what's her name I feel like
it's Rachel this tweet was so mean okay
so let me find it give me ten seconds
nine here so when they got engaged this
girl Olivia who works for the Daily
Beast's which as we all know is the
devil and she was like at Karlie Kloss
and Josh Krishna's wedding
Taylor will have a wild affair with the
best man Jared Kushner and then write
about a write a song about it
and
Trump will assault and get sued by
Taylor and then he'll get fired like
what okay sorry I was really working to
iCarly costing Josh Krishna's wedding
one of two things will happen when
Taylor Swift and Donald Trump meet
Taylor will have a wild affair with the
best man Jared and write about it too
Trump will be gross and assault
assaultive and then gets sued by Taylor
like she did that DJ like Oh everyone
hates Taylor Swift what a disgusting
thing to say about someone first of all
like that she would start having an
affair
look whatever like that's horrible it's
a horrible tweet and it's so
condescending and I feel like literally
feminism applies to everyone except
Ellis where people are so mean to tell
her stuff do but it's like that's so
far-fetched and it's not even funny oh
here's but you're gonna be like that
offensive honest girl she's an it Carly
class and Josh Kushner I met Josh
Casteel it's like what subversive things
yes hey that's gonna go viral that's
gonna bring in oh the biggest people
around Taylor Swift Donald Trump right
and I'm Tyron wait like and also Taylor
Swift didn't like just get that GJ fired
because she felt like it like he's
disgusting and I'm sure she saves a lot
of other girls from getting their asses
grabbed this is truly like so so crazy
the story is so great I feel like
they're not gonna end up getting married
I feel like I feel like they might
they've been together for a reason ever
seen paparazzi pictures of them fighting
my favorite thing is paparazzi catching
celebrity sighting the ones of unasyn
Kourtney fighting yes only ones Rihanna
and yes she was like no paparazzi photos
of couples fighting is the best thing
ever oh my god we need to start an
interim account of paparazzi pictures
I've been sighting and it's like it
looks like a really serious argument I
remember seeing it like a couple years
ago but they really have been together
that's why I know they've been together
for so long because I remember seeing a
picture like in high school
ya know they've been together for so
long and there's always been like times
are they together are they not and I
just feel like they lead I don't know
they leave they made interesting lives
but I do think that they will get
married and to give you the blind so and
D blinded know what I'm so that
basically like there will be a medic
wedding but they like won't consummate
the marriage
of course and no I just I think it's
gonna be a lavish affair I would
literally at the White House hey seven
million dollars to be a fly on the wall
at that wedding actually I'm gonna be a
fly from pink seven million dollars I
mean yes when the camera either guess
you can guess her service to the test
no it's just like
is the type of thing that I live for
this is the type of thing that
generation like it's like the royal
wedding
yeah and it's like when we look back I'm
like I don't know like Jackie O like
these at like these major people major
moments right this is one of those
moments
yes ooming the wedding happens what do
you think that they will get married
definitely like on like outdoors like
Wyoming vibe do you think our guy he's
gonna marry them
so people are so job the Kushner's are
Jewish and people are saying that she
converted she did she I only read that
in the Halle toasters I don't think
that's true and I only I didn't see it
anywhere else I don't know if it's true
but if I banca had to convert why would
he not have to make it right I know
Carlos just doesn't seem like the
converting type I don't know
oh yeah but I guess if she doesn't
convert them they won't have like a
traditional Jewish wedding and grab a
look C Mon marrying them I don't know
we'll say that's so that's what I'm
looking forward to like it's gonna be a
Jewish wedding I feel like it has to be
they're very chewy they're like so
Jewish Wow and they both married not
Jews but yessssss
and never forgot that Jared Kushner was
born a snitch as Anthony Bourdain said
it was what he said - he was born a
snitch what does that mean that he's a
snitch - who he's a snitch who does he
snitch on I don't - what about what when
did Anthony Bourdain say that right
before he died Oh in that inner in that
just really said it Jared Kushner was
quote born a snitch him and Margo should
hang out I don't think there's anything
more insulting like that's actually
seriously calling someone a snitch that
doesn't need you have like no loyalty
and that you're like just want to please
people in your [ __ ]
but snitches in a snitch she's just a
snitch you know what are the common
saying now sorry they're saying um just
Carly actually know how to code
Carly and like recent years has changed
like her branding from like a model to
like a tech computer scientist and she
like started this brand coding with
Carly that like teaches it's actually
like a good like um it's a good brand
like they help girls become like
engineers and computer science whatever
um but she apparently like knows how to
code like websites but I'm just not
buying it and she also like has a cookie
brand oh yeah and I'm not buying that
either Skinny [ __ ] doesn't eat cookies
yeah it should be
like lettuce with Carly you know yeah
actually I feel like SH maybe eat she
just seems like she was born well she's
so tall that like I feel like if she
eats a cookie like it gets to hurt like
I know it gets to her diarrhea like six
days later that's how tall she is that's
how long it takes the cookie to travel
yeah I'm not worried about her anyways
this is very exciting news and I look
forward to watching this story play out
and hearing more about the wedding
festivities it's too much for me like
all of the roads converging at this
wedding it's too much it's too much it's
exciting though it's an exciting time to
be like really cared about us they would
livestream the wedding but whatever no
they won't
but like they'll definitely have some
like AP photography it'll like it'll be
on in vogue and it'll be on NT so of
course of course of course know what
goes down I wonder if any of any of anti
sources will be guests I just hope it's
soon ish yes yeah you know yeah well it
took them like literally eight years to
get engaged to like yeah okay next story
Andy Cohen completely loses it over
Britney Spears so if any of you are on
Instagram you saw that Andy Cohen got a
piece of Britney Spears on Tuesday night
joining the popstar onstage at Radio
City Music Hall the watch what happens
live host got down on all fours as
Spears walked him with a leash while
performing her 2007 hit freak show
following the set Cohen bowed down to
the sexy singer quote I think you I
think you all know who this is give it
up for him Spears exclaimed appearing to
forget the Bravo honchos name after
signing a t-shirt for Cohen has left the
stage Spears turned to the audience and
said out ears he's loud this isn't the
first time Cohen his cross paths with
Spears telling the Bravo's Daily Dish he
greeted the mother of two with her
signature catchphrase in 2013 I said
it's Britney [ __ ] when she walked into
the room he said I've always wanted to
say that turn well it's still funny
because I read in these books and in
every single book he talks a lot about
just like the development of watched
repins live like from beginning to now
and like one of their biggest milestones
is that and they still haven't they're
trying to get Britney I'm watch happens
live some said you have a spot on your
leg I don't know what they're talking
about
you look fun I would say camera yes so
like like a guest that while chubbins
live has been really trying to get ever
since their inception and they still
have an is Britney and they got super
close ones in the book they were talking
about and Andy actually recently tweeted
before this happened like about how
they're working super hard on getting
pretty good when they get Britney like
the show will have to end do
I mean I don't think they're gonna get
Britney because Britney doesn't do
interviews Britney doesn't do anything
any well so I just think it's so weird
that she was doing a show at Radio City
Music Hall I I feel like she hasn't done
a show outside of Vegas in like 30 years
and also like she's Britney Spears and
she's performing at Radio City Music
Hall I know it's a little sad it's a
little sad the whole thing is Chad and
did you see that story that the comedian
did her conspiracy theory about Britney
Spears which comedian I think her name
is Heather Mick Mahan or something
Heather McDonald no no she is you would
love her she has this whole I think it
might be a hundred part story about her
theory about what's going on with
Britney because she was always photos
like the put pictures up Britney post on
Instagram like are not okay no and those
videos are out of control everything she
posted it's like who has help like who's
doing this to her well you remember like
when she went south her everything that
she all of her money all of her real
estate is in like a trust that her dad
controls and her dad is like not a good
guy
well it is her dad making her wear tiny
Sophie shorts and have no common well
honestly were wearing three-day-old I
makeup if you lived in Nevada you would
air tiny sofa shorts too well she
doesn't makeup is weird everything so
basically this you have to watch this
woman story I think I need to get her
name right she's literally a robot
Brittany like she just does the show in
Vegas and like it's just a robot
so Heather says that she is dead behind
the eyes she said that her theory is
that something traumatic must have
happened to her when she was about 18
because she has not matured past that
age that's very true yeah her name is
Heather McNay Hanover and she is so
funny she was also like she said that
one time she when she was living in New
York City she found three tickets on the
floor outside of Madison Square Garden
to a Britney Spears concert no [ __ ] they
were like front row seat so she brought
two of her friends and they're standing
in the front row waiting for Britney and
she got the whole stadium to chant
let's go Tigers LSU for 15 minutes
this girl girl and she's just she's so
funny that's so funny he said there's
something wrong with Britney no one's
talking about it she's wearing three day
I three day old I make up every single
day she has tiny furniture in her gym
she's wearing little so tiny for the
church has a Richard passed the year
2001 because something tyrannic must've
happened turn no one is talking about it
and it's like yeah I feel like she goes
on stage and people are like yeah moving
her arms for
up top or her she's a puppet so what
like why don't they just let her retire
I don't know because she's like she's
making money hand over fist and she from
Vegas oh my gosh sure but she has money
here no perfect no I'm saying like I
agree with you she she's fine
financially um I don't know she's not in
control of her own life and it's really
sad like she's not in control of her own
money she's not in control like her own
kids like she literally has no control
that's why I feel like she's just
completely let go like a per mental
state and like she's a robot
that's so sad like there's a robot
amongst us you guys and like no one
wants to help it
and I feel like her management team is
really just trying to make her this
light and she really is she's a pop
legend she's she's up there with like
Mariah she's there let's leave it at
that but I feel like they think if she
stops working then so she won't be that
anymore so like honestly I think before
she did her biggest residency she was
just a pop star and then now that she's
done a Vegas residency she's like a
she's an icon it's concrete I think she
was an icon before her Vegas residency
and every single night videos come out
from her Vegas residency of her being
puppeteered yeah dancing like a freak
yeah and looking sideways and
lip-syncing and I think it's actually
damaging her career yeah I think she
actually at one point was amazing singer
and amazing dancer now what she's being
remembered for us for being an amazing
puppet yeah it's like the jig is up they
jig in fact she should just retire and
like would do what makes her happy with
her kids yeah
live like on a ranch somewheres and be
separately these videos that she puts
out hey kids wanna play it's like zipper
eyes yeah mom no and there's videos of
them like chasing each other outside
what place like up I'm telling you
Christopher Walken put a robot inside of
her and now she's a Stepford wife yes by
the way we when did we watch this
oh we just we just watched separate
wives and I remember watching Stepford
Wives as a kid and thinking it was a
like a kind of a scary movie and be like
just like an epic like like a movie
about that defines our generation and
then we watching it as an adult it's
like a little stupid it's still a great
movie love it it's an amazing movie but
like I think I missed a lot of the the
sarcasm in it as a kid do you know any
sure watching movies that you loved as a
kid can be like kind of depressing as an
adult because like no or the opposite
that's like wow there's all this stuff
that they didn't even know hulis I was
laughing
clueless I can't participate in an
activity where balls fly at my nose I
had no idea what she was talking about
when I was kid now we know she's talking
about testes I remember when I first saw
hairspray and I guess amber calls Tracy
a [ __ ] and I didn't I had never heard
the word before I was like she's calling
her poor right why'd she say it like
that someone and I forgot we were
watching it they're like no she's not
calling her poor but they wouldn't tell
me what she was calling her right so
it's like she calls her poor no no other
word that rhymes with or that's an
insult I really love I really learned a
lot from like TV like I learned what
rape was from Degrassi cuz the girl got
raped and that was the less episode we
were less watch that you watch growing
up really defines who you are as a
person
I had a friend I don't movie set my
children must watch in order to like be
on the same wavelength
no I feel like but we won't really grab
watch like That's So Raven like I feel
like that's are even really shaped me as
a human being that is So Raven
and so my handle antennae shaped me as a
human totally there's no doubt about it
but also like Legally Blonde cheat me as
a human being clueless shaped me I
didn't mean like truly truly truly and I
just hope that my children have the same
appreciation for those films you know
yeah whether it's going on in the
comments no the people are saying
there's some drama in the TIAA and I
don't know what they're talking about I
know what they're talking about
what a is one of our toast or something
yeah and they're they call it like the
CIA they like investigate [ __ ] and like
find people's addresses it's so [ __ ]
why you never want to be a topic in the
TI yet what are they talking about okay
so this girl was uh in somewhere maybe
was even like Scottsdale somewhere for a
bachelorette party this weekend and they
met up as you do with like a group of
guys and they were all together like the
whole day at a pool party and she like
fell in love with this guy they like had
a date together and so she only had
pictures of it's him and the phone
number that he put in like wasn't
working or maybe she didn't want to text
him but she didn't like have his full
name so she put the pictures in the
phone number that did she thought it was
and maybe his first name or something I
should all the information give to the
ti a to the TA I was like if you guys
help me find my cell maybe the best date
and whoever needs something like you
need to find a name or a face to put in
the TA okay so they had the best day
together and she wants to find the man
of her dreams so that they continue like
their love story and the ti a finds him
he's married oh she
which is the wife hmm telling her to
turn the guy like make out and stuff
they made out Oprah's videos of
everything and so she messages the bite
being like hey girl I just want you to
know like I was with your husband this
weekend like I told he told me he was
single I'm like we were together all day
like I have videos I don't want to show
you but like I just thought girl to girl
like you should know and she was like
send me the video send me everything and
it's like videos of them like making out
they didn't do more than make out maybe
like a buck rap in a boob crap but like
the wolf wife was like was there like
what basis did he bode like how far did
it go she was like just Abby were just
together all day then wife was like did
the friends that he was with like no and
she was like yeah we were all together
like a thousand percent they knew and
it's like those friends that he was with
are like her friends too and they all
just came home and like lied to her and
I don't know what's gonna happen they
have a cat together they've been
together and they've been married for
six years and like to their kids they do
not have kids [ __ ] him and let him have
the cat cats are gross and it's legit so
crazy the ti a is insane I'd literally
like I hope I'm never the subject of a
TI a investigation
they're ruthless they're ruthless but I
learn want from them I got that at mr.
number it's the best thing ever oh I
haven't needed it yet cuz all the
unknown numbers that caught me are
telling me about my car insurance and I
don't even have a license totally so I'm
on to you anyway she is so [ __ ] wild
I was reading the messages last night
it's like the woman wanted all the thing
of the information like she wasn't one
of those women like she wasn't being low
in know or like the last time this
happened there was like some confusion
and it's like literally the man took
over the girls Facebook I'm was like
we're fine she's fine
everything's good for this girl good for
this guy he's gonna for everyone for
doing the right thing he's gonna come
with all the receipts yeah and she's
gonna leave it up but that's so crazy
they live in Canada so I don't know what
like the divorce laws are but me are but
maybe it's like you've had an affair
like then show that off all the money
yeah hopefully okay next up Odell
Beckham jr. has been baptized in
Jerusalem after being accused of paying
for sex whoa I call this one a
bittersweet okay
Odell Beckham jr. is on a new path to 25
year old NFL star was baptized in
Jerusalem this week according to a
series of Instagram photos one photo
shows the blonde athlete being dunked in
a body of murky water by a priest
other snaps show him flexing his muscles
and visiting tourist sites fresh start
he captioned the faux
what a time he also added the hashtag
Unforgiven I couldn't have asked for
anything more he also set up his trip to
the Middle East
god I can't thank you enough for this
one my journey is just beginning
all of this positivity follows a slew of
stories accusing the New York Giants
wide receiver of naughty illegal
behavior The Post reported that a man
already suing the athlete for fifteen
million dollars open alleged assault
earlier this year has evidence Beckham
attempted to pay a woman a thousand
dollars for sex a rep for the baller
said mr. Beckham does denies the
recently added allegations and further
denies any wrongdoing whatsoever related
to the alleged incident so funny like
Odell Beckham jr. got baptized in the
same place in Northwest did write that
episode of Kardashians when they're in
Israel and Kim is like wearing that head
thing and she's like in this church
where Jesus walked and they're on the
balcony and they were like two cheese's
walk here they're like yeah on this
balcony and Kim is just a mean North is
like crying in the thing and like any
baptized by that really like old scary
priest um that was epic that was that
big it's just like crazy Odell Beckham
jr. 25 prime of his career so cute still
has to pay for sex yeah that's the thing
with celebrities like I mean I guess if
you're paying for sex that mean like and
celebrities definitely use like good
companies like the girls can't take
pictures I'm like you're probably more
protected again I guess detested you can
get what you want or is they gonna pick
up a random girl in a bar like a should
separately gonna take a picture of each
other friends tell everything and she
could have a disease and like there's
just so many things so may not be down
for your level of freak actually can't
understand celebrities paying for sex
the smart ones I don't know it's illegal
well yeah but so it was like heroin but
everyone does it I don't know I just I
feel like you shouldn't that's like the
great part about being somebody like you
don't have to pay for anything yeah like
I feel like if you're like if you were
like super famous what would your
favorite part about being a celebrity I
feel like just having like a car waiting
for me everywhere I go
that is such such a good call you know
no celebrities like a car and driver
like ready to go whenever they're ready
to leave that is it
I feel like if I want to leave first of
all I'd like say bye to everyone
celebrities don't and then I have to get
a new but wait outside for my nuber and
then I see the people I said bye you
right it's like so awkward for you like
you're leaving with someone like you
both walk the same way and it's just
like so escalate to get right into like
the air conditioning already on and
some snacks and a bottle of water things
would be simpler Wow
I have the same answer under 8 it also
just like having people work for you
like people whose 21st I'm in their job
it's just like make sure you're like
happy no or like just having someone
like oh I have this idea like how do we
make it happen I suppose like me having
to go on Google and like secret stuff
out right like totally like I could say
I want to put on a camp from my
followers and like someone would do it
yeah like if Kris Jenner was like your
manager you're like hey Kris like let's
do camp toast camp to us would be done
this is almost done you guys it is um we
have a few more pieces to work out but I
think maybe patreon members can expect
next week it's Monday let's not promise
anything because the only things we're
waiting on it's like legal stuff and
that stuff does take a while yeah and
that's the most important stuff because
we want to make sure we're all buttoned
up yeah cuz we're not [ __ ] around like
or what he was um anyways what a weird
story about Odell Beckham jr. right and
the more they were really communicating
Sunday I was so here for that that's
beautiful
I know I just feel like okay you paid
for sex like that's not cute but you
know you're trying to redeem yourself
this is a really good place to start
like nothing like a baptism in Jerusalem
for a clean slate can I say something
controversial again totally it better be
controversy it is actually I don't
really get why prostitutions illegal let
me see let me see
I know you're both parties are willing
and able and they're both like they're
both down and which part is is worse is
it that the person is paying for sex or
that someone's getting paid to have sex
because I don't know I just think it's
like let people do it like it kind of
your bag this is a free country you can
do anything you want except pay for sex
like it's just so weird do you know any
mean I understand what you're saying and
I thought about it before because it's
your body you can use it to be a model
and get paid for that so why didn't you
use it however you want and get paid for
that exactly but I think the problem is
and I'm no law maker but I think it's
like if prostitution were illegal how
terrible it would become and like women
being forced into prostitution like I
think the act of it being a leak okay
you want to pose a question in the
knowledge no sorry I would love to us
finish active it being illegal stops it
from so much worse things like spiraling
in countries where it's not illegal like
then you have like all of these
red-light district yeah and like people
you know
being young girls and forcing them into
it's like the broken window Jerry and
it's like it's a very slippery slope
okay I feel that but you agree with me
though that like besides from what could
happen because if it like just the act
of prostitution like should not be Lee
but I think that's why the term escort
is so favored because it's not illegal
to be an escort I don't think and it's
like someone's paying for your time and
what you do once a have your time is
fine right and like that's what that's
the only thing I can think of when I
watch pretty woman I'm like she's like
technically a criminal but like she's a
nice girl yeah and it's like she's just
using her body yeah I just admit I've
never agreed with the prostitution being
like no I think it should be illegal
because I think it would lead to much
much worse things and like really sad
things
okay so sorry I hope really interesting
things are happy I know about I'm gonna
turn my phone off there's a guy in the
comments who's basically saying that but
honestly it's a compliment because they
said famous people should be allowed to
buy sex and he said I'm famous so like
for example like do I want to buy sex
thanks but you would only want to buy
sex from another famous person no from
only Kate Upton and not sex just kiss on
the lips right like they're buying sex
from like regular the common commoners
commoners so I don't find that that
exciting speaking of buying sex
Lamar Odom was not involved in the
Queen's Hooters shooting this story is
so crazy former NBA star Lamar Odom
escaped injury when gunfire erupted
between his pals
and another group outside a Queen's
Hooters police said the 38 year old
ex-husband of Khloe Kardashian and his
pals were at an outdoor table of The
Fresh Meadows Palace eatery when members
of his entourage got into a squabble
with the other group around 12:30 a.m.
last Thursday Oh God police said
witnesses reported seeing a man from the
other group pull out a handgun and fire
several shots into the air before
fleeing
no one was shark cops said and Odom did
not appear to be intended target or
involved in the dispute they're retired
Laker posted a message on Instagram
about the scary incident I want to let
my fans know that I am okay thank you
for your messages and I will try to
respond to as many fans as I can just
Lamar Odom relax you don't have fans
just to share the truth here with you
all I was near the scene when it
happened and not involved in any way
thanks Lamar Odom he added up thanks
comma Lamar Odom just let you know that
he wrote it ok um like this is just so
crazy you know what's so sad
I thought we reported that he was
to Europe or Asia yeah China you know
what's sad for like forever for Khloe
Kardashian is that Lamar Odom will
always be referred to as her ex-husband
like should he never be able to distance
herself from the [ __ ] show that is
sustained ya know he is like a [ __ ]
stain on the name a stain on the name a
stain um but that's like wild a shooting
at Hooters like you guys come on there's
titties I told daddy I used to think
like when we were kids like Hooters was
like literary strip like a strip club
and having been to one it's literally
just a restaurant the girls wear tight
chair it's a second on big deal it's
really not big down they wear like nurse
sneakers it's like I love less sex I
love how Britney Cartwright has become
literally like the national face of
Hooters because she spoke about it she
worked there and she spoke about it a
lot on Vanderpump rules and she like
she's literally got him as corporate she
hosted miss hooter that was just like a
pageant that they hold or some [ __ ] like
good for her like now she really could
be miss hitter because they should go on
a tour with her or like something
something did you see they she lost 25
pounds she looks so good and honestly
like I feel like I told like I can't
explain it and it's like a weird thing
to say but like I really like when
celebrities like gain weight because I
could just make a humanizes them like
yeah everyone like you could be rich and
famous but like we all can't stop
gaining weight like it equalizes all of
us so I just think it was really cool
how she was like open about it and like
she like got really upset and like she
like she I don't I just think the way
she went about it was like cool and
responsible do you only mean mm-hmm what
can I say diet I watched your Housewives
of Orange County hmm you guys look so
let's go uh okay
Kelly Dodd is my favorite housewife
currently see she was on my drive inside
with Bridget Everett ah oh my god I've
been missing watch I mean she was
literally they were being so funny but
and like they're both so funny and I
expected them to like have much
chemistry and they didn't they were just
being funny in their own way and like
barely like very much I think they were
both just so caught up in themselves
yeah Bridget Everett is honestly like an
epic human being epic she is like she's
a legend she's a legend uh so Orange
County is good
I'm looking forward to the driving up of
the season Vickie is out of control like
that last scene was so out of control
like I can't imagine being friends with
someone like yes every friends I have
disagreements but being friends with
someone who's so out of tune with
reality is like it's so frustrating I
don't know how they're friends with her
here's what they this is what happened
to Vicki she is friends with Michael
friends with Kelly she set Michael up
with a new woman and then she said to
herself I'm staying out of it and so
that's how she's been justifying not
telling telling anything but once you've
set them up you're in it and it is your
duty as if anyway she can't stay out of
it they went on a double date did you
hear that right no so you can't be like
I'm staying out of it I'm staying I'm
gonna do all these things but I'm
staying out of it once you do all these
things you're in it and now you have a
responsibility to the Kelly if you're
her friend imagine if it was if Brooks
met a woman not a party at Kelly's house
and Kelly was going on double dates with
them Vicki would have burned her
apartment to the ground
honestly I've really always been like
not team Vicki but I've never hated her
like I really like I'm on her side like
was like empathetic and like even though
when everyone hated her I hated her too
but like I was still like rooting for
her this is like Kelly Donna's only
person that can make me hate Vicki and
Kelly is shows I mean Vicki's so stupid
because of all the people like that she
burns she really should not burn Kelly
because Vicki's relevance in this group
has everything to do with Kelly and last
season when all the girls were loving
Kelly she didn't drop Vicki she could
have she could up when everyone finally
accepted Kelly she dragged Vicki with
her when she could have just let her go
and been with the cool girls totally
hidden she's being so stupid Vicki and
that conversation was so frustrating and
honestly I would not want to cross Kelly
Dodd especially not if I was once her
best friend and I'm sure she knows some
[ __ ] about Vicki you know she's not
keeping that to herself once she's angry
like she's gonna explode and I think the
only person that can appropriately take
down Vicki Gunvalson this Kelly Dodd but
this is lisaveta [ __ ] overtures
ruthless like because Shannon and Tamara
like even when they're in a fight with
Vicki it's like they just say above the
line they state fact like it's this
versus Kelly is like a below-the-belt
like she's gonna destroy her and I
cannot wait and I'm just upset that now
that he's going to Mexico with Tamra and
Shannon because Kelly deserves to be
there it should be killing out there no
because they just thought to invite
Vicki because they're like the mexican
andale is what else happened in the
episode
that fight was literally the last five
minutes um Eddie oh my god Eddie is a
woman like me honestly no no I'm sorry I
was an insult to women
he's such like a baby like first of all
he needs to understand two things one
like if Tamara can forget Vicky for all
the terrible things like you can forgive
her for like the one thing she said to
like it's not about you like relax
literally him being such like a baby
making the whole episode about him at
the dinner like at the meal I'd
literally want to punch him in the face
and then when he was laughing I'm Vicki
when she was actually giving like a
really sweet heartfelt Bible Belt
apology I didn't know what she was
talking about like he was laughing at
her that was so mean why and she was
crying and then like when she's like
kept going he like finally was like
getting more serious about it for like
laughing in her face I just I really
[ __ ] hate Eddie and three like making
it about him when it's like okay
regardless of how you feel about Vicki
like you guys are doing a job this is a
show your wife
literally depends on this show and you
know what her relationships with the
women have a lot to do with her
employment no get the [ __ ] over it and
you know what if it's not true who gives
a [ __ ] right the fact that he's like
getting so angry about it it's like
cause for concern and like that he's not
gonna let Tamra hang out with Vicki like
this is her job like and because of that
you own a gym like yep oh please [ __ ]
you whatever like you have so much to be
grateful and honestly Vicki's kept the
show afloat for so long that the least
you can do is just move on Vicki paid
for your [ __ ] heart surgery dude like
please and also him like refusing to
give up working out like I will just
never understand totally I can't stand
people even rather like God did die than
to stop working this one class with two
people by the way no one's ever at cut
Fitness ever I've never seen another
person there beside Tamra like I've
never seen someone there and also if you
love working out so much and like this
is what thrills you you still own a gym
like you right you can do this there's
so many other people you can train them
without getting your heart rate up and
I'm like that's so selfish like you have
a family I can't I can't with Eddie just
any of kids besides nothing about town
right I don't think so I think so too
it's like you have a family no yeah yeah
likes just like he's so unreasonable me
she like when the food came and he like
literally cut Tamra awesome and sentence
like boasts it down like okay you're so
winded but you're gonna go do a soul
cycle I don't understand no when they
were doing that boot camp
I was just like go home I I can't even
relate on any level to people who like
would literally like go into cardiac
arrest just her workout like it's your
doctor is telling you to stop working
out like that's a dream yeah I would do
anything to hear that and she'll can
promote your everything he's with the
agency but the agency's actually
successful
I don't know how cup is cup in the
season business but him will always with
the hats and the shirts but he doesn't
get enough [ __ ] for that everyone give
him a reseal and Kyle [ __ ] for like
having they didn't see posters excuse me
all over their house because the
agency's successful right now people are
resentful but like that's true it's the
cut Fitness were successful maybe they
stopped what they were like franchise if
Skinnygirl wasn't successful they
wouldn't be mad at her for posting her
embarrassing brand everywhere but in our
sinks because it's rich it's 150ml just
the liquor part right no I'm saying
that's what she got ball for I'm still
curious about her finances
okay this is this I thought it here's
what I know here's what we know she sold
her the liquor portion of her business
to a major liquor distributor 450 ml or
was 120 oh by the way that's so funny
that you said that cause it was bad when
I was gonna speak I was gonna say to 120
or hundred good I believe it sounds
you're 20 cuz that's what I was thinking
before she sold just the liquor part but
she kept ownership of the brand and then
spun brand out into food everything I
buy her popcorn she has lollipops she is
like meals jeans no jeans everything so
all of that stuff she owns a hundred
percent oh really
yeah because she only sold the liquor
portion which is doing so well and she
still has like she didn't just sell it
off completely like it's a partnership
I'm surprised like literally internet
channels haven't come after her for
using word skinny I thought the same
thing and also like she's doing an
inclusive line of jeans but they're
called Skinnygirl yeah it's a little uh
misleading I mean I think the name is
cute and I don't really care but like if
I can't say the word I it she can't say
the words even if she's tried to start
Skinnygirl and today yeah nobody and by
the way you know what's really crazy is
like and I know they felt they have
fought about it before but like LuAnn
really came up with the name Skinnygirl
and it's on camera but I really don't
think so like Bethenny's been saying
like this is a Skinnygirl margarita haha
like I'm like a skinny mom whatever and
lamellae she was like just like what did
she say even she said Skinnygirl no she
said it first
there's there's literally video perfect
I find that to be so annoying like I
know and no no like I don't think LuAnn
came up with it like at all
it like it's nice for her to think that
she did but she didn't who I mean even
if she's even if Betty has been saying
like this was like she made this
margarita it's skinny version it's the
skinny version missus skinny where's
Neil and causeth skinny girl oh my god
skinny girl great name like I still
don't think it's a LAN you know and like
honestly a name is one thing but like to
build a 300 million dollar business is a
whole lot of guys I go spice right by
yourself like a single girl it's so
impressive I have nothing but the utmost
respect for Bethenny and what I've heard
from you know we mean that have some
mutual friends I said everyone really
[ __ ] comes to her in the reunion but
she really stood her own and like she
she held up in court she needs us there
for her totally I think we're out here
in the comments of every post battling
for Bethenny I'm like so I can't believe
that there are people in this world who
don't agree with me I have n like every
time we have someone here who's team
Carole like I just look at them
differently so it's now Darren Stephen
and Kristin every every coalesced I've
had I go at it with that mm-hmm oh my
god I need to bring on in August some
however Bridget Everett is team Bethenny
which means we're right we have got to
have her to have her on the show she
would go she would do it go flood
Bridget Everett's Instagram like
honestly she's so epic in every way and
I just really feel like Chloe took home
and I could learn a lot from her
Oh first sure what time is it 11:30 okay
and I said one more thing to say about
the new housewives um
terrible chessy is fine but it's weird
in the chest because Emily Simpson the
girl who wants more babies and if you
are obscene if you're a toaster I will
not be your furniture anything other
than chassis so get on board um that was
a really sad scene in the fact that
they're fighting in their first scene
filming together does not bode well I
think a lot of women come on the show to
get divorced and I think of a lot of
husbands put their women their wives on
the show to give them a life to keep
them busy while they're filing for
divorce so I think that's like I don't
know if Jessie and her husband are gonna
have divorce clearly they have some
strange arrangement where they got night
over gchat
but the thing about the embryos was
really sad and I just want to say
something they were literally eating at
a diner
I was thinking she's all dressed up in
her Sunday best and there she's ordering
fish tacos at a diner and you're not
gonna no one's gonna agree with me on
this but there is an angle at which they
film her where she looks like Alexis
Bellino and you're not going to see it
and me
one day you will but I'm telling you she
is a combination of Jesse and Alexis
Bellino just look out for it what OC
needs to do was what they did with
Bethany they need to bring back like
someone who was wrong right they need to
bring back at question no but she's so
thirsty she would it would be too
annoying it would be too like should we
no single Alexis Bellino yeah like there
was a time I liked her me too there was
a time when OC was the best show on TV
like with the Gretchen it was also the
only challenge that's true
so Jessie and her husband fighting was
really sad and like it's just a little
way too personal and it's like this is
real housewives like can we be fighting
over a necklace like yeah I don't want
to fight about your embryos like I'm sad
now no it was really sad embryos and
those oh god it but I don't even know
it's just too sad and I didn't think
that they were more so fighting I just
thought he was like being a dick and
like super dismissive no it's enough
it's a lot and they both work like how
and like he would be saying and saying
we went through so much like for the
first three kids because the sister
carried them and like she had how many
miscarriages she did she had she had
five miscarriages she was pregnant with
twins for four months until she
miscarried she had to go into labor like
that's hard II it's so set and so I
totally get her wanting to have more but
I also get him like not wanting to go
through that again yeah no they're both
entitled to their feelings but I just
always love when people talk about their
fertility issues like publicly because I
feel like it's so sad like and I just
feel like it happened to more people
than you would think
and like just if someone's talking about
it like on a public forum it makes you
feel like you're less alone I don't know
yeah but it was just getting a little
too real housewife yeah it was very real
for their first scene together and
honestly I was just I mean I don't know
what happened to me I must have like
fallen asleep in the first episode
because I did not see him but when she
said he's half Mormon half Persian I was
like oh my god and then I was like what
is he gonna look like and then he's mad
cute he's mad they're mad cute I don't
totally get it yet but still there's
more to come and then the princess of
Long Island Lisa is her name I do know
Jenna I don't know why I'm getting so
who's Lisa she's me Gina she's awful she
is just no she's not awful and I feel
like she might be funny and like have
moments so I'm fine but she was like had
a lit candle sitting on her bed Jackie
on a tray I thought the same thing like
obviously she got she bought a new decor
for her
they feel where to put the candle she
put it on her bed on the burner went on
a wobbly blanket like it was a throw
blanket and then on a tray it was so
weird I was like and then she had
another candle burning somewhere else
that her like little kid was playing
with and it's like you're giving me
anxiety like blow your candles out then
film I don't want to be [ __ ] but like
I really feel like the Real Housewives
franchise is supposed to be of
aspirational people with like wonderful
lives nice jewelry big houses nice cars
and like this girl Lisa's life like
seems horrible her husband's never
around
I don't think her name is Lisa what the
hell's her name Gina Gina sorry Gina
Gina her life seems terrible like I
didn't and B her life at all like she
was alone her raising her kids without
her husband five out of seven days a
week and her house was tiny but yeah
this is show estate aspirational mind
the fact that her husband works
somewhere else is actually like an
interesting twist yes and if she were
living in this big palace like alone you
know she gets like be alone five days a
week where no makeup and like do her
thing like that's kind of interesting
but like now it's that it's just me now
I said I like to look at big